when i talk to people left wingers
people on the left about my movie most
of them won't watch it they don't no i
don't want to see that that was an
insurrection those people should all go
to jail they don't want they won't
they can't bear to look at it i even had
to fire my own agent just over the
christmas holidays because i'm i was
talking to him about uh you know
about the movie and with the premieres
and the you know stuff and he's like
yeah i'm not going to watch that i go
what dude you're my agent you you're not
going to watch my work
because you you're afraid of what it's
just a movie
michael moore makes them for your side
all the time you can't even look at it
and he said no i just i just don't want
to you know that was a that was a riot
full stop and i go well
i guess then you don't want to be my
agent anymore was that over the phone or
be a text yeah it was over the phone
weird yeah well
so i think what happens in their minds
and again maybe i'm over pathologizing
here but i think this is probably a
reasonable assessment of the potential
motivation here a person might think
okay there could be information here
that will change my mind but i don't
want to be the person who knows that
january 6th wasn't an insurrection
because there is a very high social cost
to pay for having that awareness you bet
you bet
especially in hollywood absolutely i
went back to my parents house for
christmas and they're like well what do
you think about that insurrection at the
capitol i was like what do you mean like
when they stood inside the old building
and just stood in the hallways and i was
like the government can operate from
anywhere digitally it's not a real
insurrection would be cutting off the
electricity to the to the continent like
if you want to talk about insurrection
and they were like huh he's right
well the other thing too about that day
it's like the the media only showed you
the violence they only showed you the
little pieces the clips right at the
capitol of the windows being broken and
ashley babbitt being killed and all that
that's all they showed you there were 2
million people there that day there were
so many people and they never showed you
2 million yes that we have estimates of
2 million people wow there's a shot in
my movie that i had never seen before we
found it of just the size of the crowd
and it's breathtaking i mean it's
amazing they conflate the rally which
occurred um
some some ways away from the capitol
with the insurrection
so for a lot of people like maybe like
your parents ian who don't actually
investigate and know what's going on
they're told that their their image of
this is probably trump brought
hundreds of thousands of people to the
capitol and stood outside and said go be
strong and shut it down exactly whereas
what really happened is that there was a
rally
blocks away where a bunch of people
rallied and waved little american flags
and then trump while he was still
speaking people went to the capitol yeah
and the people that were breaking in
they were breaking
windows at the capitol 15 minutes before
trump stopped speaking
who were those people this guy ray epps
that's been in the news lately he he and
his crew were taking down all the
fencing and all the signs that said do
not enter restricted area they took down
all that fencing so that when the people
walked from the speech to the capitol
building they didn't know that they were
entering a restricted area and a lot of
the defendants are charged with that
entering a restricted area and they said
that we didn't see anything that said it
was restricted is there video of ray and
other people removing those signs i've
seen some of it it's not in our movie
but i've seen what i'm concerned about
is how defects in the future will start
twisting video but for now video seems
to be a pretty good documentary
evidence kind of but i know deep fakes
are real yeah they're they're
they are real and
what do we do about them yeah
well i don't know
well but but here's the problem i mean
people are talking about deep fakes but
we have that technology is not far along
enough for us to make the argument if it
is that far along uh we don't know about
it as far as we are aware that
technology is not far along enough for
something like this to be faked but even
with the actual real video evidence that
is there and available people still buy
into the narrative yeah they won't look
at it they won't they will not take that
in it
no yeah i agree with it's like
continue your point i'm sorry didn't i
mean to interrupt no well
they just won't look at the they won't
look at the video whether it's fake or
not if it doesn't support their
narrative they just this past week they
just released three more angles of
ashley babbitt's death that were taken
from different places in the hall and
you can see ashley babbitt
was actually telling the people breaking
the windows to stop that
stop doing that ashley babbitt was
talking to the police officers and
saying what are you doing
why aren't you calling for
reinforcements there's more people
coming up here and she actually punched
a guy that was like trying to break a
window so it's like this whole narrative
about ashley babbitt being some crazed
right-wing trump supporter is absolutely
a total lie and they knew it from the
beginning
what somebody punched through a window
and then she stood up and they saw her
and they fired
yeah well the window had been broken and
you know i i don't i don't know why she
got in that window but there is there is
video of her
telling people to stop breaking stuff
stop doing that
talking to the police saying you need
more people up here you've got to stop
this she was on the side of the police
and
her husband aaron says that he he feels
like she
she he knew that she was claustrophobic
and he thinks that just sort of the
crush of the people coming up and all
the chaos
caused her to panic and to jump into the
window and that's when the police
officer fired and if you watch the video
bird the the police officer has his gun
trained at that window
for like 30 45 seconds yeah before she's
even there probably the window got
broken he was like watch that entrance
something's gonna come through there
yeah and while he's standing there
pointing the gun
people are right here beside or near him
hitting the window with with two by
fours and trying to break the window and
he never
never trains the gun on them he's
pointed right at that one window sounds
very strange
that sounds to me like um
he was angry at the person who broke the
window and wanted them to suffer
hmm that would be my assessment that
because he didn't feel threatened
obviously otherwise he'd focus on the
other side of things but i you know
my my assumption
is that he sees he sees someone smash
the window and he goes that's son of a
and he pulls his guns up come on do it
i've never have you been in combat
before yeah but
me yeah no i never well ashley was not
the one that broke the window she no i
know yeah so that's why he had his gun
drawn up the full time because he wanted
whoever broke that window for whatever
they did he was going to get him
and so when she came in she's the one
who got the bullet yeah maybe yeah so
how do how do you know i think what we
see when you know you you make the movie
capital punishment you said you just
said your agent wouldn't even watch it
what's happening is a natural sorting
algorithm is occurring people who are
willing to say challenge i i will
challenge my perceptions and that's why
you have people like bridget fedesy you
know politically homeless now more
aligned with like intellectual dark web
types conversing with ben shapiro
conservatives because these are all
people who are willing to be wrong right
and have their perception challenged
what's being sorted between it's being
sorted between two groups those who
don't want out who just want to be told
what to think and those who are more
inquisitive more discerning i mean i've
said
something similar to the to this before
there's the the uninitiated and the more
discerning the people who don't watch
the news who don't investigate and the
people who do
what is your view like so so knowing
what you know having to fire your own
agent
where do you think all this is going to
lead to with what they're doing with law
enforcement january 6 committee and the
fact that regular people are refusing to
even learn the truth where do you think
it goes
well
uh you mean in terms of the government
they're never going to give this
narrative up they're never going to stop
and what they're doing to these
defendants now is railroading them into
pleas plea deals you know most of them
are charged with you're facing 28 years
you go before a dc jury that's 96
democrat i don't like your chances if
you plead guilty to this one little
felony
then you know you maybe do six months or
maybe even you just get probation but
you can't vote anymore you don't can't
own a firearm and they are they're
basically by doing this they are
neutralizing a whole group of people
that disagree with them and the
intention that
they're trying to spread a ripple
through the community
of you know by per by prosecuting these
people so publicly
they're going to they're sending the
message that don't don't ever be one of
these people or will do this to you
so i think the government is never going
to give that up they're going to run
that into the ground and the only thing
we can do is try to fight that you just
said something very scary
you go before a jury that's 96 democrat
we can't function as a constitutional
republic if there are two tribes and i
mean that literally and they will put
you in prison if you're in the opposing
tribe yep
and another thing about that dc system
is that you have to be licensed to
practice law in dc
you can't like if you get arrested in
florida and you have a good lawyer you
can't bring him with you unless he's you
know licensed to practice in dc so all
these lawyers they're all d.c residents
96 percent of them are democrats too and
they literally hate the people that
they're defending
they want them to go to jail and so
these these these court appointed
attorneys are really working for the
government to try to punish these people
that dared stand up to the to the
democrat party they supposed the
judicial wasn't supposed to be
nonpartisan i believe it's supposed to
be at the point so when did that change
right after it got formed it's it's
cultural enforcement
it it used to be when we were a cohesive
nation that people viewed each other as
americans maybe people took jury duty
more seriously and
now because of the overt tribalism of
the culture war
we i i said it referenced to
pennsylvania it it takes it shows what's
happening here now in pennsylvania when
the republicans said hey this universal
mail-in voting law is unconstitutional
the judge's response was you're a
republican so you lose and i'm not
exaggerating yeah he said your guy lost
and now you're coming and suing
his guy he's an individual bringing a
lawsuit his political party is relevant
to the material well turns out
afterwards oh you were right it was
unconstitutional but the judge was
partisan yeah and now you have this
ruling of unconstitutionality
unconstitutionality
it's
republican judges saying it's
unconstitutional and democrats saying it
is
if we're at the point and we are if if
this is how the country's going to work
if you're a republican if you're right
winger and you advocate for a right-wing
cause in dc
you will go to prison because they will
v bro well they had that last rally i
didn't go to because what you're saying
now i'm saying if you if you do
something that is construed as a crime
i'm not saying like literally walking
down the street they're going to come
and arrest you i'm saying if you are in
a protest and advocating for something
if i'll put it this way if you brought a
boat down to dc to protest uh abortion
yeah they're going to lock you up
they're going to throw the book at you
whereas when extinction rebellion does
it it's a slap on the risk clear it out
tow it out and then send them either you
know i didn't go to the robert malone
big speech in like i think it's february
23rd or another was a month ago or some
three weeks ago and i i i i'm still i'm
almost kicking myself because i didn't
go out of fear i was afraid that the
government was going to stage a false
flag and then arrest a bunch of people
and like i don't want to live in terror
of my own government and that's
intentional that's what they're trying
to do is make everybody scared that's
that's why they're doing this to these
people that's why the overwhelming show
of force in their little suburban
neighborhoods handcuffing their wives
and daughters that's what they're doing
and even even me after i went
on january 6 and i shot a bunch of
iphone stuff and just like a tourist
i was afraid to tell anybody that i went
right after it happened because
i was like i'm not going to post these
pictures because the fbi might look
through the pictures and find somebody
you know in the show in the crowd behind
me or something it's like it was such a
pervasive attitude of like they're
they're coming after us you know right
and that is intentional so they want
what they do i think you're right about
them making an example of the people who
are involved in january 6 because i
think that's what they're doing with joe
rogan right now they're like if we can
get the biggest guy and make an example
of him and i wanted to say too let's
talk about the jury is making me wonder
if this is what drives a national
divorce i don't know that there's a way
to coexist in a world where if you get
arrested for something like a traffic
ticket or something in dc and you have
to go before a court you know for a fact
that they're going to throw a book at
you going to throw the book at you
because they disagree with your politics
how do we go on like that i don't see
that as being sustainable is there
something and and and national divorce
always will lead to
civil war that doesn't end well yeah
well so so what are your thoughts on
that there's been um there was a period
where
we had a few uh a few experts in
security say oh civil war is possible i
became particularly bullish on it saying
i think we're heading out the direction
but now we're actually getting democrat
personalities the guardian put out an
article saying the civil war has already
begun we're in it you've got the
washington post not saying the same
thing when you know when we talk about
the courts making their rulings based on
political party it's scary and then you
come to us and say oh and also the
juries themselves are comprised of
individuals who are tribal partisans
sounds to me like
civil war
well i think the reason that they're
talking about this the democrats that
are talking about civil war it's honest
that's what they want
that's what they want they're trying to
sell this idea that everybody who went
to washington on january 6 is some sort
of crazed violent you know
insurrectionist seditionist who wants to
start a civil war and created you know
that's that's the narrative that they're
selling
so i i agree yeah you want to know why
what's the one way you get rid of the
constitution
civil war yeah civil war you can't you
you can't get rid of the constitution
through any means that exists within the
current government the government would
have to be in some way split fractured
or altered
so if there was mass rioting and they
came out and said we need the
insurrection act martial law you can't
get rid of the constitution if they're
even under bush's presidential directive
51 you can't get rid of the constitution
in a civil war
the constitution is good emergency right
the direct emergency doesn't do it
director 51 is terrifying is it in place
right now yes i was reading about it
last night and it's saying like if
there's any issue anywhere uh yeah
that like economic or environmental any
like severe issue they say say the word
severes in there and who defines that
the president apparently that they can
just what is it like morph all power i
didn't i didn't go so far on it last
night but is it that they could morph
all powers under one branch
are you familiar with presidential
directive 51 no uh it's not been tested
it may just be a stupid statement made
by bush it's been revised several times
under the previous presidents i think
even trump may have revised it
basically says that if there is any kind
of disaster anywhere in the world the
president has the authority to dissolve
the government and reform it under a
single a single branch a constitutional
government so it would have to abide by
the original you know rules and um it
would the three branches of government
would be organized by uh would be
controlled by the national continuity
coordinator under the executive branch
they could try it it might go to the
courts but it's an interesting
circumstance when one branch asserts the
authority of the other two and then one
of those branches by which they're
subject subjugated by this other branch
says we reject your authority
it doesn't really make sense how that
would play out like if the executive
branch says you report to us now and the
court says we hereby decree we don't
yeah well the guys with guns are going
to show up and say yes you do yeah and
that's that's that's a power created by
bush and there's been other versions of
it but it's been updated several times
it's not a coincidence the executive
branch has the word execute in it well
that's what it means for yeah to not
only make something happen to execute
the plan but also to execute someone
that's yes literally what the executive
branch does they they're crazy they're
the ones with the guns who go out and
enforce the law
i thought they were supposed to execute
the law yeah well sure not execute the
people but i mean well that's why
they're trying to take the guns too
exactly part of it you know they want to
make sure that we can't
defend ourselves if they decide to
attack you know well let's be honest if
if they did we have seen things like
waco and uh
ruby ridge
most people would just
smile and put their hands behind their
back and go along wherever they were
supposed to be going and that's what
happened in uh let's let's use the most
the most talked about trope and cliche
nazi germany
there were a lot of people who at a
certain point just said it's getting bad
we got to get out of here
but most people just said it can't
happen here yep until it did and uh
a lot of people you know i was i've been
reading more and more about it for
obvious reasons i've also been writing
about the spanish civil war people
they'd show up to the house knock on the
door and say for your safety you're
coming with us get in the cart and
they'd be like okay let me grab my
things they'd say okay they'd take the
people off some you know often without
their things just no no take your family
you're coming it's for your own safety
you have to do it and people just said
yes we're seeing that australia
not like they're taking people in
australia to you know work camps to to
rot them out till they die
but it's crazy to me
that there is there's a video out of
australia where the cops show up to a
guy's house unannounced and they say sir
you have tested positive for covid and
you are now being indefinitely
quarantined get in the van and he goes
all right mate and he just hops in the
van and i'm just like wow
great yeah the germans used typhus as an
excuse they said a lot of the jewish
population had typhus i don't know if
that was the reason for taking them on
the trains but maybe those are like for
your own safety we don't want you to get
sick
it was one of the propaganda things they
were claiming about oh these these
ghettos are dirty and they have typhus
so they have to be taken to special
facilities and we know how that went and
you know look we look back at history i
don't think history is going to repeat
itself history rhymes
and so you know people who are ignorant
will be like oh that can't happen here
or that won't happen and it's like
probably not no to be honest some form
of it will
well see that
they don't have to actually murder you
now like they did then yeah they don't
have to murder you and dispose of your
body now they can just digitally erase
you
they can just neutralize you by by
removing your voice from the community
so it's
it'll happen differently it's like what
they're doing with rogan you know you're
you're just
you have to be careful or the government
will just erase your point of view
demonize you
destroy your ability to to
express yourselves if you have wrong
think if you have a bad opinion it used
to ostracize people throw them out of
the country and not let it back in but
now that was before electricity and
telephones and stuff yeah they don't
even have to do that now it just shuts
you down well that's why it's called
character assassination the entire idea
is you neutralize the threat that
somebody poses by telling the truth or
by stating some facts that you find to
be inconvenient and um or by lying it's
you know or by lying sure you can you
can perform a character assassination on
someone who has actually lied but yeah
it's very frightening and at some point
you wonder how much they really have to
do to cover anything up how much
information they really need to hide
from the people it seems to me
that all you really have to do is attack
and character assassinate the people who
are speaking the truth and then even if
the facts seem fishy to the general
public and they're not willing to buy
into your narrative they're going to be
too scared to say anything they take
like a wait and watch approach and if
the person ends up getting busted it
almost doesn't matter if they were right
or wrong they're like i don't want that
to happen to me right
that's why i've been saying for a while
about the police
you look at what's going on up in
ontario when that cop arrests that 78
year old man
here's the crazy thing so there's this
viral video where
seven eight-year-old man sunk in his
horn the cop arrests him this was before
honking was banned
so this is just some cop deciding to
bully an old man who walked his horn
you look at the cops who are seizing
gasoline
you look at the cops who are defending
antifa they don't care they literally
don't care and it's crazy when i meet
cops who are like i'm a big fan of the
show and i'm just like i hope you're one
of the good ones because we got too many
bad ones the capitol police are all some
really evil people i mean you look at
what they were saying on tv how they
were lying about things i get that there
was a bad fight and there was writing
and stuff i'm not discrediting that or
anything like that but it's crazy how
they're willing to just say the most
absurd and ridiculous statements i was
the next day i was you know the craziest
thing is they're like the stress that
the left is claiming the stress of it
resulted in officers taking their own
lives and stuff like that oh yeah i'm
like come on man
you know we don't know why those some
officers did take their own lives yeah
and i don't know if that's related or
not but it's just such a dirty dirty
thing they're they're they're milking
this as much as they can i will tell you
this you know i'm most frustrated with
the people who actually ride and fought
with cops and tried to break and
literally broke in the building
because it's just like
watching people you know it's like it's
like watching someone walking down the
road and they're like on the side of a
cliff and then they look to their left
and start to walk towards the cliff and
you're like please don't do that and
they go i'll be fine
like alex jones was there saying stop
don't go inside don't do it
and listen to him
a lot of young young people think
they're going to reload their save game
if something goes wrong
yeah
well if you see in the movie you just
see we have all these people suspicious
looking people exhorting the crowd come
this way you know get in here go into
the capitol break in you know they're
just constantly berating these people
screaming at them and you also have the
capitol police
who are in many instances the aggressors
here they they were firing flash bangs
and tear gas grenades and pepper spray
into the middle of the crowd that's what
driving them forward rather than trying
to keep them from coming forward they
were just firing into the middle of the
crowd and you know the stuff that
happened in the tunnel it's now being
revealed that roseanne boylan was
probably beaten to death
by a police
during officer was probably like just we
can't contain this just get them in the
building we'll bust them all later well
i don't know about that but in ferguson
one of the nights i was down at the
riots people had stopped riding and
protesting was it was uh maybe like the
fifth night they were just dancing in
the street playing music
one cop
from the police line at the at the
far end of west florescent
casually walked up pulled a flashbang
and just threw it into a crowd of
dancing people and that immediately
started a riot people then started
screaming running towards the police
yelling and then all of a sudden people
who didn't live in the neighborhood
started smashing windows and stealing
stuff
the cops did that
so when i say abolish the police i'm
telling you this right now
you look at what is going on with the
purging of wrong think
there they start by saying if you're if
you're unvaccinated there's a mandate
you're fired well guess what only the
people that fall in line as do it and do
as they're told are going to remain on
his police they're going to remain in
military then they're going to put those
national guardsmen in your schools teach
your kids like they're doing in new
mexico they're having them drive school
buses in massachusetts they're going to
replace more and more jobs because of
the emergency and the labor shortage
with national guard and they've already
purged the ranks of anybody who would
disobey who disobey the narrative
you don't want to live under that boot
so your best bet right now is just hey
call the bluff of the left yeah abolish
the police and then when they're like no
no no i thought you wanted to i think
it's funny when the left like they freak
out
because i tweeted about the police
and they're like well i mean but he
wants militias and i'm like that's
literally what you asked for yeah you
said community police what do you think
militias are yeah what do they think was
gonna well social workers actually tim
is what they want because they don't
really want to abolish the police they
want control of the police
yes no that's exactly what it is and the
police with a smile on their face face
are putting boots on people's necks it's
funny you know you mentioned the um the
police officers and yes there were
officers harmed on january 6th that's
very unfortunate however
i should point out that according to the
major city's chiefs association
72 percent of major city law enforcement
agencies had officers harmed during the
blm rights 72 percent
that is a massive number and you know i
don't care
you know i i literally don't care that
they were injured i mean i i think it's
horrible when anyone gets injured if
you're getting insulted if if you're
gonna show up to attila's gym
and arrest the owners or try and
prosecute them and seize money from
their bank accounts you want sympathy
from me the police in this country i
have no sympathy for that guy no no i'm
just look man there are there there are
small offices and departments i'll put
it this way sheriff's offices with duly
elected law enforcement oh i think
they're great they still do bad things
there was there was a woman who was
arrested for opening her cafe during
lockdown and it was the sheriffs who
came and arrested her the deputies
that's that's that's bad but these big
city police departments i'm referring to
specifically they they they they did
nothing while the riots were happening
it's true and when it happened i said
well look i don't blame them for
defending these these businesses from
people who won't support them but then
they turn around and became the vandals
who lock down their businesses destroy
these people's lives so i sit back at
these cities and i'm like y'all deserve
each other but but here's my main point
if the police departments have per are
purged of wrong thinkers and all that's
left are going to be those who toe the
line that's what we've seen over the
past two years the people the cops who
stayed on during the blm riots after all
the disrespect that's that's a great
mental test psychological test are you
willing to endure extreme pressure where
everyone hates you where we won't
support you and you shut your mouth and
get on your knees and these officers who
stayed said yes that's a good sign for a
despot they then said okay now you gotta
inject yourself with something and a
bunch of them were like nah that's too
far for me but a lot of them said yes
sir may i have another and they got
their second shot and they're boosters
and now we're at the point where you
think that these departments will defend
your right to liberty no no certainly if
there ever was a group of people who
were going to
uh who are going to goose step to the to
the barking uh marching orders of a
despot it is the modern police that have
remained through all of this refusing to
stand up for themselves
refusing to stand up for others
falling in line over overtly illegal
orders and rule by decree i'm not going
to defend any of those people yeah when
you talk about illegal orders because
it's called law enforcement so if you're
getting illegal orders from a top-down
authority and you're the law enforcement
you're supposed to not follow the
illegal order and stay lawful they don't
care about what's legal they don't know
what's legal there have been many
instances in my life where i've i've had
cops tell me that something was illegal
and it wasn't you know new york is a
great example that's a frozen zone the
cop told me and my friends during occupy
wall street and i'm like you made that
up that's not even though there's no
frozen zones they just made it up one
day
and you see what's going on with the blm
mural painted in new york city the 27
officers who defended it
on an illegal seizure of taxpayer funds
for a political message yep and the
police were like boss told me to do it
i'll arrest anybody who opposes me yo
we're in dark dark times now man agreed
i think um but
in terms of maybe this is a small white
pole but i think there's a white pill
here uh and
despite all of the media propaganda
a large number of the american people a
large swarth of the population are still
seeing through this according to erasmus
and reports survey that was done back in
july
only about 50 percent of the population
who was surveyed at that time supported
nancy pelosi's january 6th committee and
investigating that whereas two-thirds of
american citizens surveyed wanted an
investigation into the 2020 blm riots so
no matter how much they're lying about
this or trying to call this an
insurrection and tell us to ignore that
the majority of the american people do
see the truth about it thanks for
checking out this segment from the tim
cast irl podcast if you want to watch
live you can check out this channel
monday through friday at 8pm and don't
forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this channel and if you
want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time